hi I'm Chris garlic and I'm with Michael
Redmond ninth on professional and we are
going to do our 15-minute highlights of
the game - in this historic match
between alphago and Lisa doll an
exciting game really was on the edge of
literally actually Michael on the edge
of my seat today for about five hours
great commentary um and now you have to
boil five hours down to 15 minutes so
let's get started well first of all just
to give a general idea of please how I
felt throughout the game the game
started with I was really interested to
see how alphago would handle black
because with black black has the
initiative and has sort of the
responsibility to make use of that to
take control of the game because because
of the Komi that black is paying seven
half points in return for having the
first move so black has to take control
maybe move the game into a kind of a
fighting game usually to make good use
of the first move and alphago didn't
really seem to be doing that in october
when it was playing for employee so i
was looking to see how it would change
and i was very impressed because it did
and it was even more than i expected
we're still let's see the game when he
started with the star point and I was
saying Oh start points again you know
with any play with the aterna three four
you were very happy to see it was a
difference because basically because
three four point as variety to the game
it makes it much more complicated so I
was wondering if maybe alphago was
trying to avoid that at first but now
it's not avoiding it it means that it's
willing to play any kind of game
basically
now the joseki would be to play here or
here actually it's a pretty common
variation to leave it to play tendency
and play once here so this move in
itself was not so unusual usually now
after this black is going to look at
these stones is dispensable so maybe if
white continues playing the moves in
that area black might just get them up
and so black would play you something
and it's right here maybe black would
continue with something let's see a
Chinese style opening and make a moyu on
the side of the board while white still
needs one more move to finish off all
those that would be a kind of a
often-used
opening but instead alphago plays once
here and then white here we would expect
some kind of extension but it didn't
played there and after playing this one
move to play elsewhere is a bit unusual
in fact it's very unusual mm-hmm
because it does it by investing this one
move here it makes it impossible for
black to give up that group whereas if
it was just the two stones it would be
dispensable after making this exchange
and giving wipes and profit on the left
side here now it's sort of it's much
more costly for black to throw that
group away so if white plays here
there's a potential attack on the black
stones but apparently alphago wasn't a
parent I wasn't worried about that and
don't know he said well actually didn't
do that immediately chose to play this
one which is a more balanced oriented
move then alphago played a peep once and
that's again an unusual move but not
necessarily bad it does lose some
potential to try different moves but
later in the game wipe will maybe not
answer the same way so just making sure
that white answers that way it
simplifies the game in a little bit so
it's not necessarily bad
then you switch through the corner there
this is also a standard sequence in
itself Connect and black cut once this
is actually a Joseph so it's there's
nothing unusual about the play here but
the fact and then he extended the fact
that he played the corner here first and
then played the extension it's a very
good sequence here because black has to
settle these stones somehow at some
point anyway and this is an even
exchange it's a joseki it's considered
even for both players but the fact that
black played this first and decided the
shape here
before choosing the extension made it
easier you might say for black to choose
a point to extend like black has a
choice between this move or this move or
this move which is the original joseki
but is sort of slightly falling out of
favor among professionals professional
because of his weakness here but when
wet black was had not played all of this
black still sort of wanted to play all
the way out once this shape is fixed
here it's much more reasonable for black
to be pulling back like this so it makes
it adds more validity to this that this
choice that have a goal made here okay
by playing this first so it's a very
nice sequence in all the game is
probably it looks sort of even at this
point but alphago is definitely taking
the initiative and deciding what kind of
game it's going to be so with white I
would already be feeling a bit pressured
and I would know that at least it at the
best it's an even game but maybe
actually the the fact that black is sort
of taking the initiative here maybe
blacks ahead all right and I think
that's what Lisa Rowe said in the press
conference was a he felt he felt that he
was completely closed out from the
beginning of the game right and it was
the fact that black is putting pressure
on white already from the beginning of
the game and it and not making a
mistakes and then after that black will
see well I hope to show you that black
actually made all that work and the
characters lead white comes here I
usually would expect to play here yes
why was sort of hoping to jump into the
3-3 point which is very popular nowadays
it's a very popular Julis a key that
starts with that this sort sort of makes
that more difficult for white and
basically because the side here because
of the strong white group here the side
here is not so big so blacks forcing
white to play on that side which is a
good strategy and now comes the
bombshell right yeah that that was a
move that I thought it was a mistake
when it was played I thought I'd missed
so I'll actually on the server where I
was watching to make sure I had the move
right the person who
was putting in putting the moves got it
wrong he really was playing here because
which is what what he was expect and
that person had to take back that booted
guy so I got you know yeah so I was
looking at the server and it was showing
a different move but then I looked at
the game room on the TV and oh yeah so
this is the server this is the move of
the game and you know the people doing
those servers in putting the moves are
pretty strong players yeah yeah
and then black played here and actually
I think why should it just play like
this yes and lack is playing a lot of
innovative exciting moves but it's hard
to say if black has gained anything
really yet so I think that game would be
about even at this point but when white
pearls and black connects here we can
see that all of this stuff that black is
doing is coming together too and this
was the move that black wanted to play
to start a fight here and all of these
stones that were traditionally would be
called questionable mm-hmm are actually
working in blacks favor when this fight
comes up so it it's all coming together
beautiful sweets so that's why I would
sort of question push again yeah why
push black played Kissimmee cover it on
the top and this sequence is a kind of a
Tesla G sequence and it's pretty much
forced for both sides
and white white is alive there on the
side now more or less black has reduced
White's right side and then this move
that's a nice lighter fare it's not a
move that people would not think of it's
a nice-looking move and black does have
sort of escape routes for this group
here which is weak but it he has a move
somewhere around here which was sort of
connect up and and with this stone here
he has an escape sort to work this side
so it's not as if black is all that weak
so he goes ahead and place this one
playing this move before this is also
good order it moves because after this
it would not have been forcing and then
he this is the weakest point in Black's
territory room so everything that back
is doing now is it makes sense and
what's more it was looking adventurous
and now it makes sense so that's really
brilliant I think yeah when we played
these moves here and then with the
connection and just everything as you
say comes together beautifully you
really had a lovely feel to the game
yeah so now white plays here now white
is sort of planning to make an attack on
these stones to start that white plays
here this sort of cuts this group off
from the left side here so black has to
move out in this direction to set be
safe but also white is threatening this
one which is actually more troublesome
for black because it creates a weak
group here and a weak group here and if
this weak group is sort of struggling in
the center that means that that would
have a bad effect on this half of the
board and of course these stones also so
black answered by playing here and at
this point he said Oh played this move
which was a very very big territorial
mover I think this might have been a
problem because if I was white I would
play somewhere around here here to make
a more direct attack against the black
stones here and I would be let's put it
here for instance and say black runs
away somehow black might find a bit
that actually become justjust for
instance okay with a stone in this
vicinity it will be very easy for white
to jump in here right and for the time
being I think this kind of stuff would
be bigger although this is a huge move
the the value of this move is that makes
this a living group but it's not really
that weak to start with but it adds a
security also after black plays here
let's just show that white can later
jump into the corner here I do so
there's the added value there so it's a
it's a pretty big move but I think this
was actually a chance for white to take
the initiative in the center of the
board which would have effects on all
sorts of places on the board this is how
I would play you know traditionally it's
probably bad form for me to be
questioning Lisa tells me but that's how
I feel in this position and so after
black played here now if this this
connects up to sort of to the moil here
now this is going to be a moil the side
territory will be well except for the
corner here it will be more safe and
then it will be spreading into the
center which would be bad for white so
white starts the attack here set it here
here there but by instead of connecting
the diamond points here black is dodging
to the side and hoping to connect up
this direction so this is good for black
too and I think then white played once
here and then invaded and here now this
kind of indirect fight attack against
this zone and direct attack black-ass
Aquila but within indirect attack black
is gaining on the sides so this is a
very pro-life move also I played here
jump and you can see black is sort of
playing thickly a very safe way and also
it's an effective attack on white
let's just get a few more moves
and then this one so I think we can do
it because we have to wrap up I can't
really find any mistake right Black's
play right and I'm finding moves that I
wouldn't even think of here and they're
really brilliant because they actually
he actually put them together to make
them work and to sort of focus on this
attack that plaque made on the right
side I did I didn't question whites move
here for one thing that allowed that to
happen but that sort of Lee settles
style I guess but so I think we just
have to admire what alphago did more
than question Lisa those moves right I
mean it was it was a brilliant game and
I felt like Lee SEDOL fought
incredibly strongly you know right
through to the very end and it was just
you know an amazing amazing game and as
you say there was several just sort of
brilliant moves that we saw coming from
a half ago this to almost no human pro
would have thought of I think right I
think everyone was surprised by this
shoulder hit so we'll be looking ahead
to Game three which will be important to
see what alphago will come up with mix
but also Lisa doll is really under the
gun
he's Owen two now and so he's got a win
he's got a win at meal every game from
here on out so I don't know about you
but it's gonna be tough going it's gonna
be tough going
thank you so much Michael Redmond
non-professional I'm Chris Garlock
managing editor of the American Gogi
Journal thank you so much for watching
and we'll see you